the reason the government invited me to
Ghana was to help honor the year of
return the commemoration of the 400th
anniversary of the transatlantic slave
trade so Sam and I visited osoo castle
just one of the many forts from which
millions of slaves began their forced
passage across the ocean this is Matilda
gives tours here this is a very
important place can you tell us why it
was established in 1661 for treat they
were trading in gold diamond as well as
slaves there may be some people watching
who don't understand year of the return
and its significance
can you explain it for people most
African Americans have their roots from
here so it's very important they they
visit their roots to also experience
what their ancestors experienced some
decades ago it's been 400 years yeah 400
years 400 years do you see people get
emotional very last week I went on tour
with a family of five we go to their
dungeons and the man was like can you
just give me some few minutes to say a
prayer for my ancestors
so I allowed him he notes he prayed and
then the wife also chipped him she went
for no less than 15 minutes right so me
I just had to allow Hey
yes yeah yes yeah it's it's anger that's
400 years old you know that still as
that we in the United States feel though
the ramifications of 400 years later
just after that so they feel relieved
you'll be like it's good I've traced my
roots I'm fine now
I just have to go back and fill a mag I
mean mm-hmm
no lineage and ancestry is something
that if they were records kept then
that's how maybe you know but for a lot
of people it's just a blank question
mark you know so coming here
has to be such a an experience to kind
of fill in that blank and complete
[Music]
thousands of Americans have made the
trip to Ghana to reconnect with their
past including this inspiring group from
Chicago
I just stopped briefly at a hotel to
have lunch and I ran into Otis Otis told
me he said I'm here with a hundred
people from the Chicago area and we're
all here for the year of return and I
thought this is this is fate that we're
all here together I know you have guys
have a busy itinerary thanks for meeting
with us why is this so important for you
and all these people to be here well to
connect with our heritage our culture
our history as a church we're from
Trinity United Church of Christ in
Chicago and Southside and when the year
of return came about we thought it would
be so important to bring people from the
Diaspora here to to Ghana seems to me
like it's most important for young
people to come here incredibly important
and one of the things that we have been
promoting and teaching is making sure
that they understand their history how
important it is that when you understand
what our ancestors went through that we
are literally survivors of a Holocaust
the my alpha is what we call it and we
wanted our young people to have that
connection why is it important for you
to be here no it's a time to remember
those who came before us many ancestors
long wishes really deep to see those who
resisted that's a major thing that bring
up those who were resistors who fought
back and a lot of people did not make it
so many people have died on this journey
to be stripped and taken from their home
right it's kind of an awakening we've
only been free for roughly 160 years
whereas we've been in bondage for over
400 years
so physically yes we're free mentally
not so much for me personally I'm
realizing how much racial stress I'm
under every day in America I don't even
realize it
I don't even realize that when I walk
into spaces where I am a minority
I am constantly checking myself here I
don't feel that what I am here I feel
that I am at home I have an
african-american mother I have a
Trinidadian father my maiden name is
Cujo and it comes from Ghana so coming
here the first hotel we stayed and one
of the portraits on the wall is named by
somebody James Kajal did it and I was
like in the u.s. I never find anybody
with
last name it's a powerful connectivity
of so many different pieces of our
history that being here connects it all
in ways that other places can one thing
that is striking is 400 years of slavery
think about it 400 years how many
generations of people good people that
sit on the sidelines and watch slavery
occur this is a lesson that we all need
to learn is that if we see injustice
whether it's happening to us personally
or happening to our neighbors we gotta
find a way to speak out and stand up
people thought well that was maybe
resolved in the Civil War and I was like
no the Civil War may be addressed the
very beginning of it but there's so much
more to do there's always more to do so
the story and John Henry Clark says that
all history is a current event and right
now the US Congress is discussing HR 40
which is a bill that would enable
research and the proposed of the
policies actually addressed reparations
and so this is they turn event the one
thing that's on my mind was with agar
one of the guys that when we went back
to one of the slave auction castles he
said that you can either be bitter which
means you can leave here weak or you can
either be better which means you leave
here stronger and so I thought about
what that been and what that meant is
that we've seen much agony and we've
seen much pain but he's also see much
hope and must promise and must glory so
we must tell the whole story
but let us put as much infant infant
emphasis on the hope and on glory and on
the optimism as we tell the story so
that people can say well there is a
prior today if we stop and plant seeds
apple seeds on which we will never see
the shade and plant them by the children
we're gonna be ok as I'm gonna leave
here better Wow
but one of you please run for president
I can't thank you enough just an honor
[Applause]